[Music]
okay okay okay okay what's up guys I'm
Cree PhD here and we're out here at CES
2019 with possibly the highest profile
item now I want to see for myself it's
the LG rollable OLED TV so this was
actually announced last year already
you've probably heard about it but it
was kind of behind closed doors it
wasn't on the show floor for very long
there's more of a proof-of-concept this
year it's on the show floor it's real
they're showing it to people and they're
promising they're going to ship it to
real people buying it this year so I
just want to see it in person point a
camera at it and turns out it was pretty
cool so it is a 65 inch 4k OLED and it's
got all the benefits of these awesome
panels already so great vibrant colors
pitch-black blacks great viewing angles
the whole deal and that's no problem
since OLED panels are already super thin
and then it comes out of this pretty
clean looking silver box with front
facing speakers in it a lot of sound
bars have like upward facing speakers
these actually face you and then it has
three modes all the way up like a normal
TV all the way rolled down so completely
hidden in the box and then this this
sort of midway halfway down mode that's
called the line mode and it has this
custom UI of the weather and things like
that which can be pretty useful but
obviously the cool part was actually
watching the TV move up and down between
these modes actually moving the TV was
pretty quiet it was maybe eight to ten
seconds and it just sort of slowly
rolled its way up and rolled its way
down and that's pretty much the whole
shtick it's the rollable TV so that was
the Marvel of watching the silver box
open up the TV roll out the top and then
at the end of the day when you're done
using it I guess it's a TV that can
disappear into a box and not be seen now
the line mode actually gave me an idea
that I think they could do the fact that
you can stop this TV down two-thirds of
the way into this special mode is a good
start but what would be cool is if you
could actually decide on any number of
aspect ratios in between like if I was
watching a 21 by 9 movie the whole point
of this rollable adjustable TV
be if I could lower the TV to a 21 by
nine aspect ratio so there's no black
bars that would be dope
that I think would really make the whole
rollable modular TV concept pretty
interesting to people and obviously the
box is super simple it's the black grill
with the speakers but I would love if
they made like a clear box demo version
so we could see the actual TV inside
rollin up just because I kind of want to
see how it works but if you look closely
at the size of the TV it's broken down
into maybe 40 or 50 of these little
segments and they span the whole back of
the TV each and they're interlocking
with each other to keep it rigid and
then the TV disappears into this little
box piece by piece and then it folds
down and has this sort of X frame
holding it back and that X frame just
kind of like expands and contracts
holding up the corners of the TV it's
kind of hard to explain with words but I
think you visually get the idea but
that's how it works and that's the
rollable TV now what I get one honestly
probably not I mean they say it's coming
out this year but it is definitely going
to be much more expensive than any other
TV I use and I already have a wallpaper
TV which is really dope but you know you
got to admit it's gonna be expensive but
it's so pretty cool for sure I think
it's neat to see really radical and
crazy ideas of CES which can be
notoriously filled with products that
don't go on to ever exist it's cool to
see one of these ideas actually move
forward and become an actual product and
I think it does have the potential and I
think they can easily make it do these
things if you get to pick your aspect
ratio at any point that'll make the no
black bars theory possible for watching
movies and content like that so it's fun
to see maybe I'll get in the studio and
actually get to buy it and use it well
we'll find out soon either way that's
been it thanks for watching doctor guys
the next one peace